when king james vi of scotland inherited
the english throne he made it his top
priority to unify the two kingdoms into
one entity he failed but his descendant
queen anne would be the one to succeed
when in 1707 the act of union created
the kingdom of great britain in 1801
there would be a second unification with
ireland to create the united kingdom
this was undertaken by king george iii
who wanted to stop ireland from drifting
away yet as this act was being drafted
george was also the ruler of another
state the kingdom of hanover located
here in what's now germany and despite
britain and hanover sharing the same
rules for over 120 years the two never
unified which raises the question why
why didn't hanover join the united
kingdom and why did the two eventually
go their separate ways so first a bit of
background in 1714 when queen anne who
had no heirs opted out of living the
british throne passed to her closest
protestant relative george the first the
elector of hanover he swiftly moved to
britain because that's where the money
and the power were and the two kingdoms
were thereafter run separately but with
the unified foreign policy from the
beginning though the two domains were
seen as very separate entities by both
sides hanoverian culture was very
different to britain's and there was
very little in the way of shared history
between them in the same way that
england and scotland had furthermore
from the perspective of hanover the
electors leaving the country and running
it mostly from london meant that local
leaders felt that had largely been
reduced to a british puppet state and in
britain leaders there didn't exactly
have high opinions of hanover eva it was
seen as an autocratic liability since it
had previous disputes with sweden france
and prussia that britain would now have
to take a side in furthermore george the
first and the second were largely
disliked in britain since they were seen
as being too foreign and too fond of
hanover george iii had the opposite
problem and despite raining for like
ever he never visited hanover and it was
during his reign that the electorate of
hanover was conquered and disestablished
by napoleon and after his defeat there
was a lot of opposition in hanover to
the restoration of the british monarchy
there in the end though george's
representatives won out and not only was
hanover in large but it was also made a
kingdom with george as its first monarch
although not long after this his son
would succeed him as george iv so with
the same king in charge of the two
states was there any formal attempt to
unite the two nope and the reason for
this was that britain was a quickly
liberalising country with established
limits on royal and noble power whereas
hanover was not and in the wake of the
napoleonic wars few european nations
were in favor of such liberalizing
movements many hanavarians felt that
they were german and wished to distance
themselves from british meddling and
during the reign of william iv the rift
between the two nations grew british
prime minister the earl grey pressured
the king to force hanover to implement
liberal reforms these were rejected and
to many it became clear that now the
union was dead because william didn't
have any children and as such the
nation's different succession laws would
see different monarchs succeed the
throne in britain the throne would pass
to victoria and in hanover it would pass
to ernest augustus because under salic
law no girls allowed and so in 1837 when
william died the two kingdoms went their
own separate ways the british were by
and large glad that hanover wasn't their
problem anymore and the hanoverians were
glad that they could finally pursue
their own destiny without foreign
interference something which they would
proudly do for 29 whole years before
being conquered by russia and british
influence there would be forever gone
barring its occupation by them in the
wake of the second world war i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons james bissonette kelly money
maker corso wolf adam stalter jerry
landon jordan longley rod d martin wyan
hockey gustav swann spencer lightfoot
captain cydog winston k wood boogerly
wiggly marvin cassow aaron the white
words about books podcast communion
matthew shipley max and flaudio alex
schwinn maggie patzkowski marcus asner
the mug wappa corey turner anthony
beckett copper tone spinning three
plates charles the first ben evanson and
scottish trekkie